[Applaudissements]
on est en direct dans TPMP quelle
ambiance euh on va pass à l'histoire du
jour on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé mardi après-midi dans la cité de
Castellane à Marseille des policiers de
là-bas qui ont été près à partir par
plusieurs individus dont certains
cagoulé alors qu'il tentaiit
d'interpeller un dealer la scène a été
filmé et a rappelé donc à beaucoup de
jeunes la scène du film bnord et le
policier a même dû sortir son arme pour
disperser tous ceux qui voulaient
empêcher le contrôle alors ce ce
policier a-t-il eu raison de sortir son
arme et tirer on sera avec nous avec
nous dans un instant avec une une jeune
femme que vous connaissez perine salé
femme de policier qui évidemment est
inquiète comme tous les proches de
policier dans ce contexte
particulièrement tendu pour eux regarder
cette vidéo qui a fait énormément
[Applaudissements]
parler
oh merci pine d'être avec nous merci à
vous porte-parole de femme de force de
l'ordre en colère euh est-ce que le
policier eu raison oui oui oui oui oui
oui Gilles Verdez ouiou oui ah oui il
est insulté en opération insulté harcelé
obligé de fuir heureusement qu'il a un
sang-froid extraordinaire de tirer en
l'air si s'il ne sort pas son arme en
tirant en l'air je le précise mais je ne
sais pas dans
et donc et et parce que jeanluc
Mélenchon il va te dire il aurait pas dû
pas qu'il soit com tu fais je suis pas
le porte-parole de Mélenchon et s'il dit
ça dans
l'mission du tout pas du tout il les
désarmer
alors non mais donc c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui pouvoir donc là le
policier AR les
gars je respect le travail des policiers
là ils ont très bien fait leur travail
parce qu'en plus ils ont eu le courage
de poursuivre ça tuadère pas cette idée
de jeanluc Mélenchon mais non mais je
suis pas le porte-parole de Mélenchon
j'ai jamais adhéré à LFI j'ai même pas
voté pour lui à la dernière élection
peut-être voter pour lui à la prochain a
personne à gauche il est s'il est le
candidat unique de la je préférais que
ce soit c'est goen royale on va la
pousser voilà si c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le candidat unique de la
gauche je v on aime bien de taquiner
mais j'ai pas de problème j'ai toujours
été transparent et donc il veut il veut
désarmer les policiersend compte jeanluc
non mais là il dit n'importe quoi les
policiers c'est pour protéger les
citoyens et lui il prend les policiers
pour des agresseurs donc il a tort il
surtout que là s'il avait pas fait ça on
se on sait pas ce qui se serait passé
après il sa comme dans toutes les cités
à Marseille c'est pour les policiers en
général des sourissières euh ils sont
pas certains de pouvoir voilà et là
cette le fait d'avoir tiré en l'air a
permis une dispersion et ça lui a permis
de revenir et ça leur a permis de
d'interpeller de saisir 30 kg je crois
de de cannabis euh qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous ouis bien sûr euh chapeau
bas les policiers chapeau bas déjà pour
rentrer dans la cité là ouais on a vu on
a eu une vue aérienne vous avez eu c'est
un état dans l'état quoi évidemment les
jeunes de C cité de cette cité la
connaissent parfaitement la police aussi
elle y va tellement de fois que il faut
avoir euh il faut les avoir bien
accrochés pour pour pour aller dans
cette cité et effectivement il fait
preuve d'un d'un sang frroid il il tire
en l'air on voit d'ailleurs le jeune qui
avait été arrêté il a il est menoté dans
le dos qui qui s'enfuit avec avec ses
amis donc évidemment qu'il a qu'il a
bien fait de sortir son arm parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui euh il serait dans
un état grave voir voir décédé parce que
c'est une meut qui a autour là il se
chauffe hein et ça hurle donc je crois
qu'il a sauvé sa vie et celle et celle
de ses collègues donc chapeau bas pine
euh vous êtes donc femme de la policier
c'est dangereux aujourd'hui d'être
d'être fille qu' nous l'aveaz dit que
oui hein bien sûr oui évidemment c'est
dangereux d'être policier de base he
parce qu'il y a le risque inérant au
métier mais maintenant il y a aussi
cette cette forme de haine de l'uniforme
cette forme de haine qui en découle sur
les familles et là ces images là ce sont
des images qui sont malheureusement trop
communes trop courantes moi je suis
compagne de policier dans la bque donc
j'ai un bacu à la maison c'est son
travail d'aller chercher ce ce genre
d'individus qui sont donc des des
dealers des personnes qui sont
implaquées dans du trafic de stupéfiants
d'aller les chercher dans des cités
qu'ils connaissent he parce que quand on
entend des hommes politiques ou des
personnalités dire que les policiers ne
connaissent pas les cités ou qu'il n
rentre pas c'est faux ce sont justement
ces policiers là acculés par des
dizaines d'individus qui on entend
d'illeurs sur cette vidéo on entend
creverles on entend tuer-les crevez-les
donc l'objectif c'est de se faire du
flic c'est de les tuer je tiens juste à
rappeler que il y a quelques années on
s'était déjà rencontré sur ce plateau
pour parler d'un policier qui s'appelle
Éric maasson Éric maçon il a été tué en
faisant un simple contrôle de police le
5 mai 2021 ce père de famille s'est fait
tuer juste pour faire son travail
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
bah en fait ce sont des individus qui
n'en ont rien à à faire de l'être humain
qui a sous l'uniforme qui juste pour
aller sauver quoi 3 kg de stupéfiants
ils ont risqué non seulement leur propre
vie mais en plus de ça ils ont ils ont
pas hésité à aller taper des policiers
com parce que là deux policiers sont
blessés ça gagne un policier de la BAC
pardon com ça gagne un policier de la
vque bah ça gagne 2000 € c'est ça c'est
c'est ce qu'on appelle les SEM gardes de
la République hein c'est c'est le le
rempart de la sécurité C des ouvriers en
fait je vois plein de de de policiers de
bqueux et cetera qui me disent
franchement pour ce qu'on est payé
parfois on se dit est-ce qu'il faut pas
qu'on laisse couler et bon ils y vont
quand même mais après la question elle
est pas elle est pas pécunière la
question c'est la vocation d'être au
service du concitoyen c'est la vocation
d'être d'être là à protéger et servir la
population votre compagnon vous a déjà
dit je vais arrêter un jour pas du tout
oui ça a déjà été évoqué mais ce sera
jamais le cas et ce sera c'est pas c'est
pas dans le c'est pas dans le projet en
fait on fait un métier comme ça par
vocation ouis par envie et par par
résultat derrière c'est c'est tellement
entre guillemets beau d'avoir une
victime qui vient vous remercier parce
que vous l'avez aidé parce que vous avez
pu arrêter un
délinquant on parlait tout à l'heure
des en fil son uniforme est-ce que vous
sentez qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça devient
une cible évidemment ce sont des cibles
ce sont des cibles et encore plus dans
le climat actuel on sait que Al-Qaïda
avait fait des derniers les appels en
nous disant que les policiers et les
militaires suédois et et français
étaient visés par des attaques
terroriste on sait qu'on on
démentantelle des des attentats bah
quasiment tous les jours on sait qu'on a
une haine antiflique grandissante que
nos photographies de famille sont
placardé dans les hall d'immeubles de ce
genre de cité on sait que aujourd'hui
être policier c'est c'est avoir une
cible dans le dos à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui l'administration nous
demande de déménager pour être le plus
loin euh de notre lieu de travail
l'image l'image est importante la CBE
dans le dos parce que le problème des
policiers tant qu'ils ont affaire à la
crapulocratie qui est en PH d'eux jeux
dire ils ont l'habitude c'est leur
métier même si c'est c'est ces jeunes
gens là dans les le trafic de SUP ils
sont de plus en plus violents de plus en
plus équipé de plus en plus armé et
d'armes lourdes et qui n'hésitent plus à
les utiliser d'ailleurs il y a quelques
mois dans la cité de la buserine les
policiers avaient été mis en joue par
par les trafiquants de drogue à la
calache d'Ille que les crapules eux ils
ont des calaches et puis le le policier
il 9 mm
bon mais le souci c'est que derrière eux
il y a une hiérarchie qui ne les
soutient plus là il a sorti son son arme
ce policier va devoir faire des des des
des tonnes de comptes rendus de de
remplir des des des des papiers il y a
aussi une presse qui ne manque pas de de
les critiquer une certaine certaines
certaines politiques parler de
mélanchant tout à l'heure qui qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas Avard je sais pas
pourquoi le hasard le hasard qui n'est
pas Avard de critique vers la police et
et des critipes extrêmement violentes
donc il il y a un climat général qui
fait que le policier a effectivement une
cible sur son front et non son dos j'ai
une question à vous poser pine votre
votre compagnon quand il entend les les
propos de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce
qu'il devient fou devant devant son
écran fou non c'est la problématique
faut savoir que monsieur Mélenchon comme
la majorité des hommes politiques est
protégé ou et que Monsieur Mélenchon ne
veut absolument pas que les policiers
qui font sa protection soit vu c'est ça
que Monsieur
Mélenchon méconnaî un petit peu la
réalité de ce terrainl qui ne vit pas en
cité qu'il ne vit pas avec qui n'a
jamais patrouillé avec des policiers de
la BAC qu'il veut démanteler c'estes
méchants policiers de la BAC qui
interviennent tous les jours pour aller
des f qu vous entendez mchon qui dit
veut désarmer la police il dit quoi
votre V mais c'est irrationnel c'est
irrationnel là on remarque bien dans
cette situation là à Marseille que si
les policiers n'avaient pas sorti leur
armes il aurait eu non seulement un
drame mais en plus de ça on remarque
bien encore une fois que les policiers
sont extrêmement en maîtrise de leur de
leur de leur travail parce qu'il ne
tirent pas sur les individus il tirent
en l'air on n pas affaire à des cowboys
contrairement à ce que Monsieur
Mélenchon et d'autres peuvent dire ce
sont pas des cboils au contraire ils
essayent de s'en sortir en faisant le
moindre mal possible effectivement en
plus de çaain faut comprendre que là
c'est le dernier recours de sortir son
arme c'est le dernier recours et ce
dernier recours là il tire en l'air avec
quel risque d' effectivement il y a des
armes longes son des pays les policiers
sont autorisés à tirer sur la fou dans
ce genre de situation son menacé bien
sûr que oui les policiers sont autorisés
à tirer sauf que là le réflexe du
policier c'est de se dire non non je ne
tire pas non seulement pour pas
êtreempéé mais en même temps pour aussi
se dire bah on a un humain en face de
soi et on va préférer tirer en l'air
faire un peu un effet de moine eté qui
mon qu' a tir en l'air parce que
principe les jeunes auraient pu dire il
nous a tiré dessus et Cera c'est pour ça
qu'en principe conseille le tirer par
terre
mais comme ça bien été dit il va falloir
aussi rendre des comptes derrière parce
qu'il y a usage de l'arme parce que
c'est il pour pouvoir dire tout ce qui
va s'être passé derrière et ces
policiers là ont été légèrement blessés
fort heureusement que légèrement blessés
c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé d'éic
Masson qui lui a été tué sur un simple
contrôle oui mais monsieur ravier et
Jean-Michel quand vous dites dans
d'autres pays il aurait été autorisé à
tirer j'espère que vous ne militez pas
pour que ça arrive en France vous aviez
l'air de vous de dire et encore dans
notre pays une réponse ceux qui disent
que les policiers sont violents F ça
dépend des cas oui moi moi ma ma
priorité je n'en ai qu'une c'est euh la
vie du policier la vie des honnêtes gens
donc il aurait dû tirer là sur les
personnes il a il a bien fait de ne pas
tirer puisquil a il a pu il a pu s'en
sortir et continuer à essayer d'arrêter
ces crapules là donc professionnel
jusqu'au bout mais si si la situation
avait dégénéré d'avantage s'il avait été
en position de vraiment de défendre sa
vie en tirant sur quelqu'un qui qui le
Men
je naurais pas trouvé ça
scandaleux des policiers qui ont fa
cramer dans le voiture là tu penses pas
que les policiers en droit de tirer sur
les gens qui voulai les tuer vif le seul
cas c'est la
légitimeours à il est différent de C typ
recours à l'ARM il y a effectivement le
légitime défense mais ça en soit tout le
monde est bien conscient de la même
chose là en en l'état ils sont en entre
guillemets en état de légitime défense
après il y aura toute une enquête si
c'est nécessaire et les autres cas c'est
de sauver leur peau la stopper la enfin
le le périple meurtrier ou criminel d'un
individu et aussi protéger les autres
individus c'est cette fameuse loi 2017
et qui a tant fait débat mais en tout
cas ce recours à l'arme il est ultime et
nécessaire ce recours à l'arme il est
ultime et nécessaire et là s'ils sortent
leur armes c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
donc ils aurent pu être en situation de
devoir tirer sur des ind 93 % des gens
disent que le policier a eu raison merci
d'avoir été avec nous